it's been announced
that it is a real draft but it doesn't
represent who's going to vote for it yet
i hope there are not enough votes for it
it's the main reason why i worked so
hard to keep robert burke off the
it just reflects his view almost
almost
anyway
look
the idea
that
concerns be a great deal
that we're gonna after 50 years decide a
woman does not have a right to choose
the mental limits of
the supreme court decision
number one
but even more equally profound is the
rationale used
and it would mean that
every other decision
be made into the notion of privacy
is thrown into question
i i realize this goes back a long way
but one of the debates i had with robert
bork was whether
whether
griswold versus connecticut should stand
as law
the state of connecticut said that the
privacy of your bedroom your husband and
wife or a couple could not choose to use
contraception the use of contraception
was a violation of the law
if the rationale of the decision as
released
were to be sustained
a whole range of rights are in question
a whole range of rights and the idea
we're letting the states make those
decisions localities make those
decisions would be a fundamental shift
in what we've done
so it goes far beyond in my view
if it becomes a law and if what is
written
is what remains
it goes far beyond the concern of
whether or not there is the right to
choose it goes to other basic rights the
right to marry the right to determine a
whole range of things
because
one of the issues that this court
many of the members of the court
a number of the members of the court
have not acknowledged is that there is a
right to privacy in our constitution
i strongly believe there is i think the
decision of his wall
was correct over ruling i think the
decision in roe was correct because
there's a right to privacy it can be
limitations on it but it cannot be
denied
do you think it's
differently changed the court
[Music]
well
you know if if this decision holds
it's really quite a radical decision
um and again
the underlying premise and again i've
not had a chance to thoroughly go into
the report the
decision
but it basically says
all the decisions related to your
private life
who you marry
whether or not you decide to conceive a
child or not whether or not you can have
an abortion a range of other decisions
whether or not how you raise your child
what does this do
and does this mean that in florida they
can decide they're going to pass a law
saying that same-sex marriage is not
permissible it's against the law in
florida and so there's a whole it's a
fundamental
shift in american jewish truths
i'm not prepared to
make those judgments now
about uh but you know uh i think the
codification in a row
makes a lot of sense look i think what
rose says
roe says what all
basic mainstream religions have
historically concluded
that
right that the existence of a human life
and being
is the question
is it at the moment of conception is it
six months is it six weeks is it
is it quickening like aquinas argued i
mean so the idea that we're going to
make a judgment
that is going to say that
no one can make the judgment to choose
to
abort a child
based on a decision by the supreme court
i think goes way overboard
thank you thank you
for the midterms what does this mean for
the democrats argument in the midterms i
haven't thought that through yet do
changes need to be made to the court in
light of this if this decision holds
i believe do changes need to be made to
the court in light of this if this no we
just have to choose it i mean look one
of the reasons why
i voted against a number of the members
of the court they refused to acknowledge
that there's a ninth amendment that
refused to acknowledge there's a right
to privacy because i mean
there's so many fundamental rights that
are affected by that
and i'm not a lot i'm not prepared to
leave that to the
whims and
the
of the public at the moment in local
areas thank you so much thank you guys
come on guys